well Stephen Fitzpatrick is founder and
chief executive of the energy supply ovo
he supports the price cap and James Kirk
up is director of the social market
foundation and independent think-tank
that campaigns for fair markets it
opposes the cap well still let me start
with you first
I'm price is the main thing on which
competitive compete particularly smaller
challenger brands like yours this is
going to make your job harder isn't it
no I think that energy companies that
focus only on price are doomed to
focusing on a very small part of the
market that is very active and shops
around and over we're very focused on
technology customer service and
sustainability and we've been able to
grow our business very quickly over the
past seven years without overcharging
anyone but isn't isn't it the case in
New Zealand where they introduce
something like this you just have a
bunching up of prices towards the top of
the cap you're going to get better value
offers taken off the market aren't you
there will be less competition I think
probably what's going to happen is that
energy companies that are currently
reliant on quite a small group of
customers they're SVT customers to make
a large amount of profit and they will
be hurt by this and it you may see them
withdrawing some offers from the market
but what will certainly happen is that
new entrants existing small suppliers
and those are going to come into the
market will fill that void very quickly
I don't think consumer is going to be in
any way harmed by this what about the
electricity proportion of dual full
towns because a lot of the energy
companies actually make a loss on
supplying electricity it's a bit of a
loss leader and they make their money on
on gas supply I mean you will see
electricity bills go up if the gift gas
prices are capped on you
I think the raise your profits between
gas electricity differs so for example
you take British Gas who have a majority
of their customers are gas customers
they have very high gas prices and it
helps them to be more profitable and the
opposite is true of some of the other
the big six that started off life as
electricity only companies so I don't
think that's a an accurate portrayal
that the market will evolve and I think
what will happen
you ever see a price cap on standard
variable rates you're going to see
consumers saving hundreds of millions of
you'll see a drive towards
differentiation and innovation on
dimensions other than price for example
technology and sustainability and so on
and you're going to see a real catalyst
or an embracing of the market by new
sector of consumers they feel maybe not
enable more to trust the energy market
and so I think it's good news on all
fronts all right James let me bring you
at this point so what do you make of
what Steven said this is this is going
to be good for innovation and good for a
lot of customers are you all should
start out by saying yeah I wish Steven
really well I think you from the
perspective of customers we want a more
competitive energy market we want more
entrance coming in challenging the big
six putting them under more pressure my
concern about energy cap like this is
that actually you this will make it
harder for Steven because what we're
talking about is customer engagement the
problems even right identifies is that
we've got quite a lot of people who
don't get involved in the market they
just whatever reason they stay stuck on
the same tariff they pay more than they
should because they don't shop around
they don't they don't look around what
their options are now weddings research
at the SMF into this issue and what
we're finding is that actually when
someone government comes along and says
we'll reward you will protect you for
being a loyal for sticking with your
your supplier some people will say ah so
Kailyn I'll yeah I'll just take that I
come even less likely to shop around and
switch and what we want whatever you
want policy via policymakers regulators
everyone's been talking for years chap
on your item in Iran saying you you we
have unengaged consumers we want more
engaged consumers and my concern is that
this you will in terms notice is going
to end up as less well I'm beyond the
evidence that on where we're collecting
at this life so far is that
unfortunately it will it will mean that
people are less likely to engage with
the market unfortunately I think
evidence is shown over the last 18 years
of increase in energy prices that it
hasn't been enough for 56 percent I read
earlier that it claimed to never switch
any supplies hold on 27 percent to the
market switch between 2012 and 2015
according to the CMA and I think
suspicion is that it's a small section
of the market that are very engaged and
switching very often whereas the
majority of customers are paying very
high prices and I would ask the question
of the SMA and also the CMA they talked
about wanting to provide incentives for
customers to engage but that's fine for
economics what it translates to in the
real world is higher and higher prices
that's the incentive and it doesn't work
in the real world people are already
paying very high prices and over the
last 18 years it hasn't worked
look let's switch energy supply their
mobile phone provider I mean should be
kept in them as well well the
interesting about the mobile phone
market is that people tend to re-engage
in the mobile phone market every two or
three years when they replace their
handset and I think this is what makes
energy a very different case for the
last 18 years we've had competition
theoretically and yet it hasn't
benefited the majority of customers in
the UK and the regulation that we have
had has served the engaged population
very well we have a very active very
dynamic segment of the market and then
another sigma of the market where
consumers are being exploited and I
think that's the the section of the
market that regulation should be
targeted at and that's why we welcome
this this price regular in an ideal
world it wouldn't be necessary but
evidence is shown that nothing has
changed over nearly two decades all
right James very very briefly target
times in the market agree with
everything here I think Steve said that
we should be targeting the about that
unengaged section I don't think yeah I
think you very right I think offering
rewards to to switch probably won't work
I think we have to look at some slightly
more creative ways of maybe defaulting
people into a basket of consumers who
would then be auctioned off to to the
lowest bidder so that your companies say
oh god I offer a low 12-month price and
then put it up later I haven't finished
writing the paper yet but yeah I thought
yeah it should be easy for you to
compete for we thought for that business